here now for the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences Jane Fonda
mrs. Anthony Center of Atlanta Georgia
has written to us saying I understand
what the ex rating for a film means but
could you explain to me the difference
between G PG and our ratings well let's
see mrs. Center if a man and a woman
take a picnic basket into the woods open
it spread a blanket under an oak tree
and sit down and have a picnic that's a
G rating if a man and a woman opened
their baskets spread a blanket and get
under it
that's a PG rating and if a man and a
woman go to the woods and don't have a
basket and don't have a blanket but they
have a picnic anyway
that's an r-rating
thank you when our next presenter was
appointed to the US mission to the
United Nations she told the General
Assembly I've gone to many of your
countries I've seen the rites and I've
seen the wrongs but I've never been
anyplace I probably wouldn't have stayed
and I've never been anyplace from which
I couldn't come back to my country well
she's home again and it's nice to have
you back where you belong
Pearl Bailey
very very much and one thing before I
even say anything about this tonight
it's not written and you can put the
cards down because I memorized my part
except for the other I have to say while
I'm looking at all of his friends hello
to a man who must be watching tonight
and I hope you say a large hello to him
I love him very much god bless him mr.
Bing Crosby
that's Lancer red to the net over the
people I know I worked at for years and
if I've ever fallen in you just sing the
biggest bounce you ever seen in your
life you know the world is getting
smaller all the time and well is that
Robert Redford he's over there and
Giannini he's over here somewhere but
films films make very good ambassadors I
told you to put the cards down I know
this far I put them down he always made
good ambassadors they bring people much
closer together and they make them feel
all warm and wonderful
that's especially if they are good films
well now everybody's looking saying what
in the world is she going to be
announced before hmm I'm going to be
what they would pick only me for who's
been around so much and speak so many
languages
Mamma Mia there's Mia boom bah bah
shukran and y'all so I am for the
nomination of the Foreign Film Award and
this is where I have the glasses and I
will read from the Ivory Coast black and
white and in color from France Cozine
Kazan that means cousin cousin from the
German Democratic
like that from the German Democratic
Republic Jacob the liar
and from Poland nights and days from
Italy seven beauties
hahahaha and the winner is I was there
darling the Ivory Coast for black and
white in color
I feel a little bit like I Truman when
he was holding up the newspaper saying
that Yui had won the election ladies and
gentlemen dear friends I was privileged
twice before to receive this award for
the garden of the finzi-continis and for
sky above mat below ironically all three
films have in common that they were made
against well meant advice and that they
were made without any commercial
concessions or considerations whatsoever
I believe it is a tribute to the Academy
that it has chosen black and white in
color a film entirely made in remote
West Africa
directed by jean-jacques I know a man
who had never directed a feature film
before and played by a cast of excellent
actors albeit unknown I would like to
say that it is this kind of recognition
and of encouragement which keeps our
industry fresh and alive and ever
created thank you thank you thank you
you